[Music]
one of the most engaging narratives
there is in anime is the dynamic between
a student
and a teacher it's such a joy to watch
when a student and a mentor or a teacher
finally clash whether with malicious
intent or not whatever the case
these battles serve as benchmarks of our
characters and their progress
now let's see which characters end up
making the cut for some of the most
emotional moments that pit
pupil against mentor as usual i'd
encourage you to subscribe to the
channel
just hit the subscribe button up there
and you can access these videos as soon
as they get released i've got a lot more
planned for this channel so you want to
be the first in line when that happens
hit subscribe ring the bell and sit back
as we take a look at some of the best
student versus teacher battles in anime
we start off with jiraiya vs pain
[Music]
naruto fans prepare the waterworks as we
take a look at one of arguably the
biggest game changers in the whole of
naruto shippuden i'm sure that even
non-naruto fans who know the series
would have heard of how jiraya tried to
take on every pain in this recon mission
now if i were to comment on the fight
i'd say that it's the perfect way for
jiraiya to go nothing else would suit
him better than to go down fighting an
unwinnable battle and he had to go
through conan beforehand
even in that state he still manages to
take down a few pains before finally
losing in such a dignified manner it's
one of the saddest moments that the
series has to offer
it's been a long run for jiraiya and i
don't think that there's a better way to
write him out than what this mini ark
did
this is the official passing of the
torch to naruto who would use this fight
as motivation to grow even stronger to
avenge his mentorship
even the strongest heroes have their
sidekicks and students the unfortunate
burden of the latter is the way to being
compared to their far
more powerful mentors so you've got to
imagine the amount of pressure someone
like jenos would go through had he been
a regular person
i think that the main selling point of
this fight is just how all out it is
one punch man fights have always been
wild but have you seen how generous went
to it
he shows off a lot of crazy moves and
even seemed to have the upper hand on
saitama at one point the problem though
he is facing saith alma and the whole
show that he puts up
is all for naught still good try though
for jenos beating saitama is just an
impossible mountain to climb but he
looked really cool and powerful even in
defeat
we move on to yuruichi vs soifon it's
the battle of speedsters as we go to the
climax of the soul society arc while
ichigo is busy with some other fight we
see the conclusion of another side plot
with the final confrontation between
soifon and yuroichi it's a joy to watch
the two take the fight to the woods and
blitz their way through the trees in a
furious back and forth exchange of
hand-to-hand combat
however i think that what sets this
fight apart from the other concurrent
ones in the arc
is how personal it is ichigo's fight may
have more stakes and be more spectacular
as a fight
but it can't even come as close to how
personal this fight is here we get the
full backstory of the two
and we see how soifon grew resentful of
a former mentor
it also ends in one of the more
heartwarming reconciliations that this
arc had to offer
now that all the talk about students and
mentors is getting you pumped up
i'd like to introduce you to the
sponsors of this video skillshare
ever found yourself having some down
time and wanting to make those moments
productive
well skillshare is here to help
skillshare is an awesome online learning
community that caters to aspiring
creators from all over the world
it's the premiere platform for online
learning which allows us to explore our
skills and develop them in a fun and
enjoyable manner the platform offers
lessons on art and animation
creative writing music photography and
more
i'm personally very interested in
learning how to draw or write
being an anime fan and all thanks to
skillshare i managed to take those
passions further with the platform's
amazing classes you could check out
patrick brown's lessons on capturing
motion for a star
as it helped me tremendously with
learning the staples of character
illustration and how to make my
characters feel alive and you get to do
all of that learning
without ads too now i'd like you to join
in on the fun so here's what i've got
for you the first 1 000 subscribers who
click on the link in the description
will get a one month free trial of
skillshare
now that sounds good right that's why
you should hurry up and grab this
opportunity
asap unleash your creativity today by
joining skillshare and i hope to be able
to learn alongside you all
how about taking a look at the classics
with roshi vs goku
[Music]
yeah not a super representative this
time but one from the og
dragon ball roshi vs goku is one of my
earliest memories of a student versus
teacher fight and it came at the heels
of a wack tournament arc people might
think that the fight would be a blowout
but goku had come prepared both have
become masters of the kamehameha
and that proves to be the great
equalizer for roshi's eager student
let's not forget that goku at this point
also has his abe form which allows him
to further chip in on the difference
between him and his master
in the end it's still roshi who wins but
goku looked really strong even in defeat
goku is not quite there yet but in a
short time he would eventually go on to
become a character strong enough to
wreck planets and create endless
who would win debates in real life
we proceed with a showdown between two
grim reapers goro sensei
vs reaper 2.0 i find it so fitting that
the last boss of assassination classroom
would be a student of sorts to goro
sensei not one of his current students
mind you but a former fanboy who looked
up to tentacle guy for his killing ways
this is the reaper or reaper 2.0 as he's
called years after taking on goro
sensei's mantle the reaper finally got
his chance to bring down goro sensei for
good unleashing his final form
a sinister looks similar to the friendly
yellow teacher we've come to love along
with the sinister form comes sinister
power
the overwhelmed goro sensei at the start
reaper would have won had he not made
one big mistake harming one of goro
sensei's dear students
this ultimately leads to his doom but at
least he has a claim to fame of being
able to knock around the seemingly
invincible koro sensei
following that we have midoriya and
vaguely versus all might
going up against the world's number one
hero for a final exam is no easy task
even if there's two of you how about
doing so as a pair of rivals who at
times just can't stand each other at
this point you gotta wonder which is
harder
be in all might or actually learning how
to work together the latter proves to be
an insane challenge for the team of
midori and bakugou it takes a while but
they eventually get some of it done
bakugo's all-out attacks aren't as
effective as expected but it's
midoriya's save that proves to be
instrumental in determining the result
of the exam
in truth this wasn't a battle of
strength despite it being hyped as a
collision course of powerful forces the
actual fighting was never the point to
begin with it was a test of willpower
and mindset
and the two prospective heroes passed
the test with flying colours
[Music]
finishing up the list is chiron vs
achilles
as much as the face series has epic
fights i always felt that it lacked the
student teacher dynamic in the mainline
series it's not a big loss or anything
like that but i felt that having this
kind of story backdrop would be epic in
something like the fate series
well apocrypha is not mainline but it
counts and the student teacher fight
came in the form of one of the best
hand-to-hand battles the whole franchise
had to offer it's not the main event
but with how good the two legendary
heroes went at it it might as well be
their last fight was just a joy to watch
not just for the graphical prowess at
work but also due to the level of
personal stakes the fight had
some people have been calling this fight
better than other standouts like the
cowboy bebop fight and that's really
saying something
it also showcases the best part of
student teacher battles that i mentioned
earlier it showed the growth and
development of both individuals with the
student finally managing to overcome his
greatest challenge it may have come in
the form of a brutal fight but i think
that chiron finds some pride in raising
a student up to be such a mighty fighter
and that's the end of this list i'd love
to know what your favorite student
versus teacher fighter i'm always on the
lookout for more examples of epic fights
to watch so your opinion does matter a
lot if you had fun with this video
don't forget to hit the like button and
check out the numerous ways to support
the channel whether it's memberships or
my patreon which i'll be linking
if you're the type who likes analysis
videos more i'll also leave a link to my
other channel which features those sorts
of videos let's try to get the other
channel rising up the ranks too don't
forget to check out the sponsors of this
video
skillshare the links in the description
i hope to see you next time so make sure
to come back for more there's a lot more
to come so i'll see you next time on
vinnie tube
you